j half got off to a good start
and struggling a little bit recently but
the biggest thing for him is going to be
able to control the rosarios cesar
hernandez d-h batting right-handed digs
in
to center field racing over
making the catch
is celestino went away one down and now
cleveland shortstop ahmed rosario
there's a line drive right field pretty
well hit down the line it's a fair ball
off the wall played well by lorna
but hustling into second base with a
stand up double is ahmed rosario
here's andy rosario the former twin with
the runner at second
popped up right side
alanko playing in short right field and
it's ceno drifting back into fair
territory the taller of the two made the
catch for the third out
the indians will send the hometown boy
to the mound in sam henches but he's
walked the first battery faces and now
josh donaldson
stroke solidly to left field
so some deep counts a 3-2 walk to
polanco
and a 2-2 sharp single by donaldson
mark's going to be up there looking for
a big two-out hit
to center and down for a hit larnick
delivers a two-out two-strike hit and
the twins take the first lead you know
two-strike approach and
tries to stay through the middle hit
this thing off the end of the bat but it
stayed through it enough if he tries to
pull it in a similar you know with a
similar swing as he did the pitch before
that strike three two down for the
number nine hitter andrewton simmons
twins with the runner on leading the
indians one to nothing
a drive to left field off the bat of
simmons and it is gone a two-run home
run
andrewton simmons hitting his third
and the twins take a three-nothing lead
[Music]
wins on top of the indians three to
nothing third inning rivera the indians
catcher number eight hitter today
batting 240.
there
that's in the zone launched deep center
field becca celestino he's out of room
it's out of here into the indians
bullpen renee rivera's second home run
on the year and the indians get on the
board here in inning number three
josh donaldson starts the home third
twins on top three to one first pitch of
of the drive left field and deep back it
goes deep it goes and gone
deep to the second deck of the u.s bank
home run porch number 11 for donaldson
and the twins quickly regain a three-run
lead it's a 4-1 twins advantage
and for sam hentges the pitch counts
already at 54.
twins lead 4-1
runner at first with two down for miguel
cenote
sharply hit a base it to center field
jeffers will hold up at second base and
snow back in the lineup today has a walk
and a single here's the 2-1 pitch
swung on popped him up right side of the
infield a huge out for hinches clement
the second baseman squeezes it and sam
hinches keeps the indians in this game
there's polanco to bat
didn't mean to
flying short right field and oh a
terrible collision the ball drops and
naylor
is in pain
oh
[Applause]
running into ernie clement in short
right field
a
hard-nosed guy and
he's a tough young kid he's
he's a considerable amount of pain
josh naylor involved in the collision
with second baseman ernie clement
and naylor appeared to seriously injure
his right leg
and being carted off the field here at
target field now nelson cruz the batter
with two down
a drive to left field it won't matter
a three-run bomb for nelson cruz as
we've seen so many times nelly cruz can
play till he's the age of 40 because he
doesn't miss that pitch jay ramirez 395
career extra base hits
broke his bat
and that's a fair ball is this going to
be an extra base hit he's going to go to
second
and there won't even be a throw helmet
stays on number 16 in terms of doubles
for jose ramirez but he was able to keep
it fair that's one ball that he was able
to get inside to the right-hander
but you can see fairball easily
here's eddie rosario a pop-up and a
ground out
ground ball single in the left coming
around third ramirez will score and the
indians will get a run back here at 7-2
eddie rosario with rbi number 43 on the
year two on two out here's miguel
cenotes snow with a walk in a run scored
in the second his first walk in three
and a half weeks
and he lost him three straight walks
after two strikeouts to open the inning
nelson the only lefty in the cleveland
pen will come in here to pitch to a rise
with the bases loaded and two down
missed
four straight walks
after the inning started
with two strikeouts
minnesota eight cleveland two ninth
inning harold ramirez has struck out
twice and single
fastball fieldmark gets a quick strike
out of ramirez third time that he's
chased a high fastball and struck out
bradley zimmer walked his only time up
chopper left side donaldson far to his
left makes a great play
[Applause]
also having to deal with the speedy
runner the guy who can
get down the line in a hurry
first catch it
then the footwork and then a perfect
throw and a good stretch on the other
end so eight to two minnesota tribe with
a runner two down in the night oh for
three on the day
fly ball right field retreating as
larnick
and that'll wrap it up a convincing 8-2
win for the twins
[Applause]
well this is the kind of home stand you
needed the kind of series you needed
you're gonna have to continue
to play this type of winning baseball
great start from jay happ nice job by
the bullpen it's a big home run some big
two out hits this game had a little bit
of everything that you'd like to see
from the minnesota twins